?
>> INDEED.
DAVE MACKENZIE, ELENA GIOKOS,
MANY THANKS TO YOU BOTH FOR
THOSE LIVE REPORTS.
WELL THE ROLLOUT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS VACCINES ACROSS
EUROPE, A YEAR AGO, WAS SEEN AS
A LANDMARK MOMENT.
OFFERING SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT PROTECTIONS AGAINST
THE DEADLY VIRUS.
HOPES OF VACCINES USHERING IN A
SWIFT AND TO THE PANDEMIC HAVE
PROVED ELUSIVE.
SARA LAWYER REPORTS ON THE
PROGRESS MADE SO FAR AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT STILL LIE
AHEAD.
>> ONE YEAR AGO, EUROPE STARTED
VACCINATING EN MASSE.
THE WORLD MARVELED AT THE UK'S
IMPRESSIVE EARLY ROLLOUT, WHERE
IT ABOUT SUPER FREEZERS,
KEEPING VACCINES COLD ENOUGH.
AND HOPED THIS WAS THE
BEGINNING OF THE END OF THE
PANDEMIC.
WHEN YOU'RE ON, EUROPE IS IN
THE GRIP OF A NEW WAVE OF
COVID-19.
FROM CURFEWS, TO LOCKDOWNS, TO
WORKING FROM HOME, RESTRICTIONS
ARE BACK IN MULTIPLE COUNTRIES,
SO HAVE VACCINES REALLY KEPT
THEIR PROMISE?
>> WHEN IT COMES TO SAVING
LIVES, THAT IS A RESOUNDING
YES.
>> ALL OUR EXPECTATIONS IN
TERMS OF THEIR EFFICACY, AND
PARTICULARLY THEIR ABILITY TO
PREVENT SEVERE DISEASE AND
DEATH.
>> AS FOR PREVENTING INFECTIONS
--
>> IT SEEMS TO BE LESS ABOUT
STOPPING PEOPLE ACTUALLY
ACQUIRING THE VIRUS.
>> STILL, COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SLOW TO VACCINATE HAVE
PAID THE PRICE IN HUMAN LIVES.
TAKE BULGARIA, THE EUROPEAN
UNION'S LEAST VACCINATED
COUNTRY, ONLY 26% UPTAKE, HAS
THE WORLD'S HIGHEST MORTALITY
RATE.
THAT REALITY HAS PROMPTED ONCE
RELUCTANT AUSTRIA TO MANDATE
VACCINES FROM FEBRUARY.
WITH GERMANY POISED TO FOLLOW
SUIT.
HOW LONG DOES IMMUNITY LAST?
THAT, PERHAPS, THE BIGGEST
DISAPPOINTMENT.
>> IMMUNITY WANES, IT'S A BIT
LIKE GOING DOWN THE HILL.
IT'S A STEEP DROP OFF, SO IF
YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED FOR
MONTHS AGO, YOU ARE LESS
PROTECTED, THEN IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED 2 OR 3 MONTHS AGO.
>> FORCING EUROPE TO BET ON
BOOSTERS, AND FRANCE, ALL
ADULTS WHO WILL LOSE ACCESS TO
RESTAURANTS, BARS, TRAIN
STATIONS AND MORE, IF THEY FAIL
TO GET THEIR BOOSTER BY MID
JANUARY.
THE HEAD OF THE FRENCH
SCIENTIFIC COUNSEL ARE ALREADY
TALKING ABOUT A 4TH DOSE.
IS THE HOLY GRAIL OF HEARD
IMMUNITY STILL ACHIEVABLE?
THE SHORT ANSWER, NO.
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS
ACHIEVABLE ANYMORE.
YOU PROBABLY NEED TO HAVE WELL
OVER 95% OF THE POPULATION,
WITH SOME IMMUNITY.
IT'S GONNA BE TYPICAL TO
ACHIEVE THAT IN PRACTICE.
>> AS EUROPE PREPARES FOR ITS
2ND COVID CHRISTMAS, QUESTIONS
ABOUND THE OMICRON VARIANT,
IT'S TRANSMISSIBILITY, IT'S
SEVERITY.
VACCINES, BY NO MEANS, ARE A
SILVER BULLET, BUT STILL, BY
FAR, THE BEST PROTECTION
AVAILABLE.
CYRIL VANIER, CNN, PARIS.
>> JOINING US FROM OXFORD
ENGLAND, IS DOCTOR SEAN
GRIFFITHS WITH, SHE IS AN
AMERICAS PROFESSOR AT THE
CHINESE UNIVERSITY OF HONG KONG
AND LED HONG KONG'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE 2003
SARS EPIDEMIC.
THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR ALL THAT
YOU DO.
>> GOOD RUNNING MORE OARS MARY,
NICE TO BE WITH YOU.
PFIZER NOW SAYS ITS 3RD COVID
BOOSTER SHOT OFFERS PROTECTION
AGAINST THE NEW OMICRON VARIANT,
BUT 2 DOSES MAY NOT BE ENOUGH
TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE 2 NEW
STUDIES FROM ISRAEL HAVE FOUND
THE PFIZER BOOSTER SHOT REDUCES
INFECTIONS AND DEATHS BY 90% OR
MORE.
WE SHOULD KNOW MORE BY FRIDAY.
HOW ENCOURAGED ARE YOU BY THIS
NEWS?
>> IT'S ENCOURAGING RESULTS.
WITH A SHOW IS THAT THE VACCINE
BOOSTERS WILL PROTECT TO SOME
EXTENT, AGAINST OMICRON.
THE BIG QUESTION WHEN OMICRON
CAME ON THE SCENE WAS, WILL
VACCINES WORK?
HOW IS THE SEVERITY OF THE
DISEASE GOING TO BE?
WHAT IS THE REAL NATURE OF THIS
VIRUS?
SCIENTISTS AROUND THE WORLD ARE
WORKING IN DIFFERENT WAYS ON
DIFFERENT STUDIES ON THIS
QUESTION.
WE KEEP GETTING SMALL HINTS OF
WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE
EVENTUALLY.
IT IS ENCOURAGING.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE CAN
JUST SIT BACK AND LET OMICRON
RIP.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS THE CASE
AT ALL.
>> HERE IN THE UNITED STATES,
THE CDC SAYS THAT ONLY ABOUT
25% OF VACCINATED ADULTS HAVE
ACTUALLY RECEIVED THAT 3RD
BOOSTER SHOT.
GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE JUST LEARNED
ABOUT THE EXTRA PROTECTION OF
THE BOOSTER SHOT, IS IT TIME TO
REDEFINE WHAT FULLY VACCINATED
MEANS AND MAKE IT A 3 SHOT,
INSTEAD OF 2-SHOT REGIMEN?
>> THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT
NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED BY
VARIOUS COMMITTEES, SUCH AS IN
THE UK, THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
VACCINATION AND IMMUNIZATION.
WE ALREADY HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION IN THE UK OF
HAVING BOOSTERS.
ALL ADULTS TO HAVE A 3RD SHOT.
AND PFIZER AND MODERNA OF THE 2
VACCINES BEING USED.
I THINK AS YOU SAID EARLIER, IN
FRANCE, THE VACCINE POSSIBLE
RELY ON PEOPLE, THE OLD PEOPLE
HAVING 3 SHOTS.
WE ARE INTO --
WE ARE DEFINITELY NOT INTO THIS
IS GOING AWAY TERRITORY.
WE ARE INTO CONTROLLING THE
VIRUS, WE NEED TO STAY ON TOP
OF THE VARIANTS, WE NEED TO SEE
DEVELOPMENTS IN VACCINES THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
VARIANTS THAT EMERGE, AND I
THINK WE MAY WELL SEE OURSELVES
IN A SITUATION LIKE WE ARE WITH
THE FLU, WHERE WE CONTINUE TO
BE VACCINATED AGAINST STRAINS
OF VIRUS THAT ARE PREVALENT AT
THAT PARTICULAR TIME.
THAT IS JUST A PRECAUTIONARY
PUBLIC HAVE APPROACH.
>> UK PRIME MINISTER BORIS
JOHNSON IS IMPOSING TOUGHER
COVID RESTRICTIONS ACROSS
ENGLAND IN AN EFFORT TO CONTAIN
THE OMICRON VARIANT.
AND OF COURSE IN THE WAKE OF A
GOVERNMENT SCANDAL.
BRITS WILL NEED TO WEAR FACE
MASKS IN MOST PUBLIC PLACES,
WORK FROM HOME WHERE POSSIBLE
AND SHOW CALWOOD PASSES TO GET
INTO KNOW NIGHTCLUBS AND OTHER
CROWDED EVENTS.
WILL THESE MEASURES BE
SUFFICIENT TO CONTAIN THE
THREAT?
>> THAT IS REALLY DIFFICULT.
THESE MEASURES ARE COMING ON
TOP OF OTHER MEASURES.
COMING OUT OF TIME OF YEAR WHEN
WE ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF
VIRUSES, NOT JUST COVID.
CIRCULATING IN OUR POPULATION.
WE HAVE PRESSURES ON THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM FROM OTHER THINGS
THAN COVID.
I THINK THAT TO OUR SCIENTIFIC
ADVISOR WHO WAS POINTING OUT
THE KEY THING WE NEED TO DO IS
SLOW THE GROWTH OF OMICRON.
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
IT AND HOPEFULLY THESE MEASURES
WILL CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF THINGS.
IT'S GETTING VACCINATED,
GETTING THOSE SHOTS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
AND THE BOOSTER PROGRAM HAS
BEEN WRAPPED UP.
GENERAL PRACTITIONERS ARE
ALLOWED TO DIFFER OTHER WORK,
OTHER ROUTINE WORK TO
PRIORITIZE BOOSTER JABS.
BOOSTER JABS ARE REALLY THE
KEY.
THESE OTHER MEASURES ARE PART
OF THE WHOLE PICTURE AND
HOPEFULLY TAKEN TOGETHER, THEY
WILL CONTROL THE SPREAD OF
OMICRON.
BECAUSE WE ARE ALL GETTING
TOWARDS CHRISTMAS.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY QUEEN
THAT WE DON'T CANCEL CHRISTMAS
THIS YEAR.
>> IT APPEARS THAT WE ARE ALL
HAVING TO LEARN WITH LIVIN